请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
好
各位媒體朋友們大家好
那今天主要是公布
我們今天已經正式公告的
我們修正了公布注意
跟處置的相關規定
那公布注意跟處置的相關規定呢
我們是在民國84年定的
那最主要的用意呢
就是在有價證券呢
展給有異常波動的時候呢
可以適度去提醒投資人呢
注意交易的風險
那這個措施呢
原本就是維持市場秩序的中性的措施
那到目前呢
已经因应各个阶段市场的变化
我们也历经多次的检讨修正
那为了要落实公平安全跟透明的资本市场的管理规则
并提升交易的效率
所以证教所这边
从上半年就开始启动相关的机制的一个检视
那我们综合考量的近期市场的变化
那過去呢 實施成效跟相關的影響
以及各界呢
對住意及處置相關規定的一個建議以後呢
那證交所這邊呢
修正了處置有價證券的處置期間
撮合作業的時間
以及公布住意交易資訊的標準
那這個修正案呢
我們今天公告
那從115年8月10號呢
正式實施
那以下呢
為各位報告一下呢
修正的相關內容
第一項
就調整處置的期間
那第一次跟第二次呢
含以上呢
招發布處置的有價證券
那處置期間呢
修改為5個營業日
原来是10个营业日
那第二点呢
如果招发布处置的有价证券呢
在计算发布处置基数的期间内呢
同时有因为呢
当中交易占比过高
而公布注意交易资讯者
那原本的处置期间是12个营业日
修正后呢
缩短为7个营业日
那第二项
是调整普通交易有价证券的撮合作业时间
那第一次跟第二次的以上的
那个被发布处置的普通交易的有价证券呢
其撮合作业时间呢
我们参考呢
目前呢
瞬间价格稳定措施
暂缓撮合的时间
调整为呢
每两分钟撮合一次
那原来的规定是第一次处置是5分钟
第二次处置是20分钟
那现在余率呢
缩改为2分钟
那第三点呢
你修正公布注意第11块
6个营业日收盘价起期加查的一个标准
那依照修正以后的规定
当日呢
收盘价呢
超过1000块以上的
而且最近六个营业日
收盘价起期价差达300元以上
才适用本款的一个规定
所以当收盘价超过2000元呢
价差的金额调整为每1000元为一个集聚
那每一个集聚的价差呢
增加150块
所以有可能呢
适用这项规定的话呢
我们原本是最近六个营业日
那个收盘价差呢
在一百块以上就可能适用
那价差每五百块为一个急剧
每一个急剧是加二十五块
这是原来规定
那现在放宽了
所以举个例子来说的话呢
股价超过一千块到两千块之间呢
价差的标准是三百元
那价差呢超过2000元到3000元的价差的标准
就是300块再加150块就是450块
那以后呢以此类推
那本市修正以后呢
我们将建立一个定期检查
检视的一个机制
原则上呢我们每半年会定期去检讨
来因应股市的一个相关的一个变化
接着呢 更会报告
修正规定以后的实施呢
如果目前还在处置期间内的有价证券呢
怎么去试用
那原则上呢 有以下三点
第一点呢 已经符合修正后处置的日数者
从实施日起及解除处置
例如呢 依照新规定处置五个营业日
或七个营业日者
如果到14日前
已经处置期满的话
就从14日起解除处置
第二点
如果还没有符合新规定的处置日数的话
则处置到建满五个营业日
或七个营业日为止
例如
截至14日
仅处置三个营业日的
人需呢
持续处置到五个营业日满
或七个营业日满
就解除了
那第三点
从修正规定实施日起呢
除了变更交易方法
变更交易方法
且采行分盘交易者呢
其余受处置有价证件的
戳合时间呢
一律都改采呢
每两分钟呢
戳合一次
那以上呢
就是這一次的一個修正
請問各位媒體朋友有沒有問題
台股量能的依註會是多少
這個應該是
這是一個中性的處置
主要功能在提醒投資人
要注意交易的風險
所以我們並沒有去估計
對量能的一個影響
量能還是要回歸到基本面
以及綜合各種國際上的政經變化的一個情況
為什麼沒有考慮到一次乾脆取消好了
這個我們很努力的在有各種方案的討論
然後請我們監事部經理是簡單說明一下
我們這次的調整呢
是希望能夠兼顧適度的提醒跟維持必要的流動性
所以呢
我們把每次的5分鐘
跟20分的交易縮成2分鐘一次
事實上我們的市場
當初也是從2分鐘慢慢縮減成到現在的主比交易
但剛才發言有報告
我們未來會定期的檢討
不管是數據方面
我們現在這次的調整
是先從縮短時間跟縮短處置的日期開始
未來我們承諾每半年都會做一次調整
以上報告
請教一下,之前有人在批評說,儲置股在大漲的時候也儲置,可是大跌的時候也儲置,這個部分你可以說明嗎?
市場監禮的措施基本上是一個中性的措施
那漲跟跌基本上我們都不能監
不能
要都要兼顧這漲跟跌的部分
所以換句話說我們在所有處置規定裡面
都是漲跟跌是並列的
所以呢我們不可能因為漲的部分或跌的部分
造成大家可能覺得會助長或助跌
而造成它的不平衡
剛剛跟各位報告過
就是這是一個中性的機制
所以我們實施這個制度
本身的用意就是在有價證券
漲跌波動很大的時候
去提醒投資人注意他的交易的安全
所以不管漲或是跌
我們都會提醒
上禮拜就是整個台股大跌
然後造成很多儲資股
它因為沒有量
儲資的時間拉長
就是那個成交的時間拉長
所以造成很多股票
它是賣不出去的
那針對這個部分
我們有沒有再去做一個整體的考量
就是這個部分有沒有可能
有特別的
就剛有提到
半年後會檢討一次
那半年之後
有沒有可能針對這個部分
如果還有這樣的一個情況發生的話
在國際上
他們是有這樣的一個制度嗎
類似的制度
不完全一樣
然後說
之前處置
好像我們這邊有分析過
並沒有邁不出去的狀況
是流通性會稍微受一些影響啦
但是還沒有發生說賣不掉邱森要不要說我想處置大家最在意的應該是預收款券的問題預收款券的確會造成流動量降低
當然也是另外一個角度
預收款券也是為了市場的秩序
跟交割的安全
我們希望能夠降低交割的風險
所以才有預收款券這個制度
那當然未來各種可能性的考量
我們都不會排除 所以我們告訴跟大家報告說半年我們會來檢討
不管是量化方面或者是交易方面
報告請教 就是這樣之前有討論到熔斷的這個機制嘛
那其他國家都有 那既然剛才講所有可能性都有在討論
那是不是有討論到熔斷機制的可能性
我們目前並沒有考慮熔斷機制 像熔斷的話
美國有這個機制
然後韓國有這個機制
那美國是沒有漲跌幅的限制
那韓國是漲跌幅是30%
那台灣漲跌幅只有10%
所以相較之下呢
我們並沒有要採取壟斷機制
但是呢
我們有一個動態的
盤中的價格穩定措施
就是那個價格變動呢
相差3.5%的時候呢
我們會暫緩戳合兩分鐘
所以大概也一樣會有冷卻的功能存在
還有沒有其他問題呢
還蠻巧合的就是在上個禮拜
就有網路在討論
然後上午也有委員在討論
然後下午這個制度就更改
這我想不可能
就是說制度這麼快就去改變了
那如果有聽說好像
就是好像券商公會這邊
就是券商這邊好像有些也不太知道
這個改的過程
那想說這個
大概花了什麼多久時間去討論這個30年
應該是沒錯因為30年第一次改這個制度
大概這個調整的過程
花了多久時間去討論這件事情
謝謝
我們每次調整呢
都會去跑一下呢
過去執行的狀況
歷史的數據啦
那不斷的修正
那也分析一下呢
就是每次處置之後呢
對這些受處置的個股的
一個相關的影響性
那不斷的在想呢
什麼方式比較好
所以不是效率,剛是效率很慢,我們研究了半年以上
因為我們說大概以後也是大概半年會去檢討一次
在處之前會先有警示,你們有針對這些警示的一些很多的項目去討論到這部分內容
剛才發言人報告的,我們對於每一個數字,我們都有去試跑過
那當然這個整個決策的過程,我們做了半年左右
今天自踏出第一步啦,所以未來我們當然會再做
再根據市場的狀況,我們會做更深入的研究跟數據的探討
請問現場還有媒體需要提問的嗎?
不好意思再問一個,之前有人覺得盤中的健身制度還是有人為材料的空間在
我不確定在這次的改變,但我們剛才陳如的長官講的只是第一步而已
那我不確定未來會不會進一步減少人類材料的空間
而增加是以制度作為基礎的這個處置的規則這樣子
謝謝
監視制度基本上我們的標準都放在官網上面
所以沒有人為材料的這種事情
都是按照數據電腦跑出來的結果
所以呢 各位可以在我們的官網上面看到所有監視的標準
不管是周轉率 不管是當充比率 不管是等等的各種數字 漲跌等等
通通都是有數字做著正的 所以絕對沒有人為裁量這種事情
補充一下 我們每一款都會有量化的標準
所以去看一下我們相關的規定
說實在 叫我算完 真的算不出來
所以事先都是透過電腦層次去設定
所以算出來數字是死的
所以很難有人為考量的空間
8月10號的生效是按照8月10號當天公布
隔日開始實施還是按照8月7號
對 禮拜五是8月7號公布從8月11號開始實施
法規的公告
法規的公告今天就實施了
所以在處置期間的
就是適用新的這些期間的規定
然後8月10號應該是
8月10號必須處置的開始適用新的規定
所以各位手上都有一張對照表
那這張對照表呢
就把中間從今天開始到禮拜五
中間過渡期間的所有處置股票
那麼它的適用狀況
給大家給證券商給投資人一目了然
可以看得出來
那麼8月10號以後就完全適用新的標準
比如說我們那個新聞稿裡面的第五項
我們就有去區分
就是說我們今天法規已經公告了
所以如果已經符合修正後的處置日數的話呢
看怎麼去計算
如果還沒有符合的話怎麼算
那8月10號以後就完全是新的計算方式
請問現場還有媒體需要提問的嗎
最近媒體也都很關注的
擔保維持率的一個問題
我在這裡說明
其實證交所一直都是秉持
资讯透明投资人保护
以及市场稳定的三项原则
为证券市场及投资人提供服务
这也是证交所很重要的工作
资讯透明是证交所的责任
更强调市场上所需要的是负责任
当责的资讯透明机制
那近期内呢
因为有部分媒体呢
频繁报道呢
引用一些呢
不是很完整的计算因子去推估融资的担保维持率
那这个部分呢
并不是投资人整户呢
担保维持率
所以为了要避免呢
引发市场不必要的疑虑跟投资人的误解
所以交易所这边会适时去说明
那这个课题呢
交易所也會持續研議
跟主管機關持續的去溝通
那我們比較呢
其實媒體所報導推估的單保維持率呢
是指的是個股的單保維持率
那我們在市場的監理方面呢
其實單保維持率的概念是這樣
是證券商跟投資人之間的關係
因為證券商把錢呢
或是股票借給的投資人
那會收一些擔保品
所以他是在控管呢
他的受信的一個風險
那所以對個別個別投資人呢
都會計算一個擔保的一個維持率
那是對個別的客戶
那他的計算基礎呢
是算整戶
比如說對A客戶是算A客戶的擔保維持率
對B客戶是B客戶的擔保維持率
那他整戶的概念是
他包括所有的上市上柜
因为不管借什么
都是券商把钱或股票借给他们
所以包括上市上柜
也包括融资跟融券都一起算
所以担保维持率过低的时候
他就会发出通知信函
给投资人说他应该要补缴担保品
所以證券商不會去看個股的
個股跟投資人說實在也沒有直接的關聯性
因為投資人關心的是
他到底跟券商借了什麼東西呢
單保品夠不夠呢
這個才是比較重要的
所以針對這個部分呢
大概我們做一個觀念上的澄清
我們有寫一個比較完整的說明
主信有給他們嗎
對,然後給各位媒體朋友們做一個參考
請問現場的媒體記者們有問題需要提問的嗎?
好,那現場的媒體記者沒有問題需要提問
那请问副总这边还有要继续说明的事项吗
OK 那如果大家没有问题的话
那我们记者会呢就到这边结束
谢谢大家
好 谢谢
谢谢大家麥克風
麥克風
喔
音樂 音樂 音樂 音樂 音樂 音樂
音樂 音樂 音樂 音樂 音樂 音樂 音樂
我們可以拿輕一點嗎
好 各位媒體們 媒體朋友們 大家好
那今天主要是公布
我們今天已經正式公告的
我們修正了公布注意跟處置的相關規定
那公布注意跟處置的相關規定
我們是在民國84年訂的
最主要的用意就是在有價證券漲跌有異常波動的時候
可以適度去提醒投資人注意交易的風險
這個措施原本就是維持市場秩序的中性措施
到目前已經因應各個階段市場的變化
我們也歷經多次的檢討修正
那为了要落实公平安全跟透明的资本市场的管理规则呢
并提升交易的效率
所以证教所这边呢
从上半年呢就开始启动呢
相关的机制的一个检视
那我们综合考量的近期市场的变化
那过去呢
实施成效跟相关的影响
以及各界呢
对住意及处置相关规定的一个建议以后呢
那证交所这边呢
修正了处置有价证券的处置期间
撮合作业的时间
以及公布住意交易资讯的标准
那这个修正案呢
我们今天公告
那从115年8月10号呢
正式呢实施
那以下呢为各位报告一下呢
修正的相关内容
第一项就调整处置的期间
那第一次跟第二次呢
以上呢
招发布处置的有价证券
那处置期间呢
修改为五个营业日
原来呢是十个营业日
那第二点呢
如果招发布处置的有价证券呢
在计算发布处置基数的期间内呢
同时有因为呢
当中交易占比过高
而公布注意交易资讯者
那原本的处置期间是12个营业日
修正后呢
缩短为7个营业日
那第二项
是调整普通交易
有在证券的撮合作业时间
那第一次跟第二次的
以上的那个被发布处置的普通交易的有效证券呢
其撮合作业时间呢
我们参考呢
目前呢
瞬间价格稳定措施
暂缓撮合的时间
调整为呢
每两分钟撮合一次
那原来的规定是
第一次处置是五分钟
第二次处置是二十分钟
那现在余律呢
所改為2分鐘
第三點
修正公布注意第11款
6個營業日收盤價起氣加差的標準
依照修正以後的規定
當日收盤價超過1000塊以上的
而且最近6個營業日
收盤價起氣加差達300元以上
才适用本款的一个规定
所以当收盘价超过2000元
价差的金额调整为每1000元为一个集聚
那每一个集聚的价差增加150块
所以有可能适用这项规定的话
我们原本是最近6个营业日
收盤價差在100塊以上就可能適用
那價差每500塊為一個級距
每一個級距是加25塊
這是原來規定
那現在放寬了
所以舉個例子來說的話
股價超過1000塊到2000塊之間
價差的標準是300元
那價差超過2000元到3000元的
价差的标准就是300块再加150块
就是450块
那以后呢以此类推
那本市修正以后呢
我们将建立一个定期检查
检视的一个机制
原则上呢
我们每半年会定期去检讨
来因应股市的一个相关的一个变化
那接着呢跟会报告
修正规定以后的实施呢
如果目前还在处置期间内的有价证券呢
怎么去试用
那原则上呢
有以下三点
第一点呢
已经符合修正后处置的日数者
从时事日起即解除处置
例如呢
依照新规定处置五个营业日或七个营业日者
如果到时事日前呢
已经处置期满的话呢
就从实施日起解除处置
第二点
如果还没有符合新规定的处置日数的话
则处置到届满五个营业日或七个营业日为止
例如截至实施日仅处置三个营业日的
仍需持续处置到五个营业日满或七个营业日满
就解除了
第三点
从修正规定实施日起呢
除了变更交易方法
变更交易方法且采行分盘交易者呢
其余受处置有价证件的戳合时间呢
一律都改采呢
每两分钟呢
戳合一次
那以上呢
就是这一次的一个修正
请问各位媒体朋友
有没有问题
台股量能的益助會是多少
應該是
這是一個中性的處置
主要功能在提醒投資人
要注意交易的風險
所以我們並沒有去估計
對量能的一個影響
量能還是要回歸到基本面
以及綜合各種
國際上震驚變化的一個情況
為什麼沒有考慮到一次乾脆取消好了
這個我們很努力的在有各種方案的討論
然後請我們監事部經理師簡單說明一下
我們這次的調整呢
是希望能夠兼顧適度的提醒跟維持必要的流動性
所以呢我們把每次的5分鐘
20分的交易縮成2分鐘一次
事實上我們的市場
當初也是從2分鐘慢慢縮減成
到現在的主比交易
但剛才發言有報告
我們未來會定期的檢討
不管是數據方面
我們現在這次的調整
是先從縮短時間
跟縮短處置的日期開始
那未來我們承諾
每半年都會做一次調整
以上報告
請教一下,之前有人在批評說
儲置股在大漲的時候,就是個股大漲的時候也儲置
可是大跌的時候也儲置,這個部分你可以說明嗎
市場監禮的措施基本上是一個中性的措施
那漲跟跌基本上我們都不能
都要兼顧
這漲跟跌的部分
所以換句話說
我們在所有的處置規定裡面
都是漲跟跌是並列的
所以呢
我們不可能因為漲的部分或跌的部分
造成
大家可能覺得會助長或助跌而造成它的不平衡
剛剛跟各位報告過
就是這是一個中性的機制
所以我們實施這個制度本身的用意
就是在有價證券漲跌波動很大的時候
去提醒投資人注意他的交易的安全
所以不管漲或是跌我們都會提醒
上禮拜就是整個台股大跌
然後造成很多儲自股
它因為沒有量
儲自的時間拉長
就是那個成交的時間拉長
所以造成很多股票
它是賣不出去的
那針對這個部分
我們有沒有再去做一個整體的考量
就是這個部分有沒有可能
有特別的
就剛有提到
半年後會檢討一次
那半年之後
有沒有可能針對這個部分
如果還有這樣的一個情況發生的話
在國際上
他們是有這樣的一個制度嗎
類似的制度
不完全一樣
然後說
之前處置
好像我們這邊有分析過
並沒有賣不出去的狀況
是流通性會稍微受一些影響
但是還沒有發生說賣不掉
邱森要不要跟說明
我想處置大家最在意的應該是
預收款券的問題
那預收款券的確會造成流動量降低
那麼當然也是另外一個角度
預收款券也是為了市場的秩序跟交割的安全
我們希望能夠降低交割的風險所以才有預收款券這個制度那當然未來各種可能性的考量我們都不會排除
所以我們告訴跟大家報告說半年我們會來檢討
不管是量化方面或者是交易方面
不好意思想請教就是這樣之前有討論到熔斷的機制嘛
那其他國家都有那既然剛才講所有可能性都有在討論
那是不是有討論到融斷機制導入的可能性
我們目前並沒有考慮融斷機制
像融斷的話
美國有這個機制
然後韓國有這個機制
那美國是沒有漲跌幅的限制
那韓國是漲跌幅是30%
那台灣漲跌幅只有10%
所以相較之下呢
我們並沒有要採取融斷機制
但是我們有一個動態的盤中的價格穩定措施
就是那個價格變動相差3.5%的時候
我們會暫緩戳合兩分鐘
所以大概也一樣會有冷卻的功能存在
還有沒有其他問題呢
好 請說
就是還蠻巧合的
就是在上個禮拜就有網路在討論
然後上午也有委員在討論
然後下午這個制度就更改
這我想不可能
就是說制度這麼快就去改變
但如果有聽說好像
就是好像券商公會這邊
就是券商這邊好像有些也不太知道這個改的過程
那想說這個大概花了什麼多久時間去討論這個30年
應該是沒錯 因為30年第一次改這個制度
這個調整的過程
花了多久時間去討論這件事情
謝謝
我們每次調整都會去跑一下過去執行的狀況、歷史的數據
那不斷的修正
那也分析一下
就是每次處置之後呢
對這些受處置的個股的一個相關的影響性
那不斷的在想呢
什麼方式比較好
所以不是效率高是效率很慢啊
我們研究了半年以上
那因為我們說大概以後也是大概半年會去檢討一次
在處置前會先有警示,你們有針對這些警示的一些很多的項目去討論到這部分的內容嗎?
剛才發言人報告的,我們對於每一個數字我們都有去試跑過
那當然這個整個決策的過程我們做了半年左右
今天自他出第一步啦
所以未來我們當然會再做
再根據市場的狀況
我們會做更深入的研究跟數據的探討
請問現場還有媒體需要提問的嗎?
不好意思再問一個
就是因為之前有人覺得說盤中的健身制度
其實還是有它的人為材料的空間在啦
那我不確定說在這次的改變
當然我們這樣剛才陳如的長官講的
這只是第一步而已
那我不確定這人
未來會不會進一步減少人類材料的空間
而增加是以制度作為基礎的
這個處置的規則這樣子
對 謝謝
今天制度基本上我們的標準都放在官網上面
所以沒有人為裁量的這種事情
都是按照數據、電腦跑出來的結果
所以各位可以在我們的官網上面看到所有監視的標準
不管是周轉率、不管是當充比率、不管是等等的各種數字、漲跌等等
通通都是有數字做著正的
所以絕對沒有人為裁量這種事情
我們每一款都會有量化的標準
所以去看一下我們相關的規定
說實在叫我算我還真的算不出來
所以事先都是透過電腦層次去設定
所以算出來數字是死的
所以很難有人為考量的空間
8月10號的生效是按照8月10號當天公布
隔日開始實施還是按照8月7號
對 禮拜五是8月7號公布從8月11號開始實施
法規的公告
法規的公告今天就实施了
所以在处置期间的
就是适用新的这些期间的规定
然后8月10号应该是
8月10号必须处置的
开始适用新的规定
所以各位手上都有一张对照表
那这张对照表呢
就把中間從今天開始到禮拜五
中間過渡期間的所有處置股票
那麼它的適用狀況跟給大家
給證券商給投資人一目了然可以看得出來
那麼8月10號以後就完全適用新的標準
比如說我們那個新聞稿裡面的第五項
我們就有去區分
就說我們今天法規已經公告了
所以如果已經符合修正後的處置日數的話呢
看怎麼去計算
如果還沒有符合的話怎麼算
那8月10號以後就完全是新的計算方式
請問現場還有媒體需要提問的嗎
最近媒體也都很關注的
擔保維持率的一個問題
我在這裡說明
其實證交所一直都是秉持
資訊透明
投資人保護
以及市場穩定的三項原則
为证券市场及投资人提供服务
这也是证交所很重要的工作
资讯透明是证交所的责任
更强调市场上所需要的是负责任
当责的资讯的透明机制
近期内因为有部分媒体频繁报导
引用一些不是很完整的计算因子去推估融资的担保维持率
那这个部分并不是投资人整户担保维持率
所以为了要避免的引发市场不必要的疑虑跟投资人的误解
所以交易所这边会适时去说明
那这个课题交易所也会持续研议
跟主管机关持续的去沟通
那我们比较呢
其实媒体所报道推估的担保维持率呢
是指的是个股的担保维持率
那我们在市场的经理方面呢
其实担保维持率的概念是这样
是证券商跟投资人之间的关系
因为证券商把钱呢
或是股票借给了投资人
那会收一些担保品
所以他是在控管他的受信的一个风险
所以对个别个别投资人都会计算一个担保的一个维持率
那是对个别的客户
那他的计算基础是算整户
比如说对A客户是算A客户的担保维持率
对B客户是B客户的担保维持率
那他整戶的概念是
他包括所有的上市上柜
因为不管借什么
都是券商把钱或股票借给他们
所以包括上市上柜
也包括融资跟融券都一起算
所以担保维持率过低的时候
他就会发出通知信函
给投资人说他应该要补缴担保品
所以證券商不會去看個股的
個股跟投資人說實在也沒有直接的關聯性
因為投資人關心的是
他到底跟券商借了什麼東西呢
單保品夠不夠呢
這個才是比較重要的
所以針對這個部分呢
大概我們做一個觀念上的澄清
我們有寫一個比較完整的說明
主信有給他們嗎
給各位媒體朋友們做一個參考
請問現場的媒體記者們有問題需要提問的嗎
好那現場的媒體記者沒有問題需要提問
那请问副总这边还有要继续说明的事项呢
OK
那如果大家没有问题的话
那我们记者会呢就到这边结束
谢谢大家
最新脈動
按讚 訂閱 開啟小鈴鐺